في غضون ذلك قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
قواتها تصدت لهجمات اوكرانيه في اتجاه
السردار واضافت ان القوات الروسيه صدت
ايضا هجمات اوكرانيه في محاور
وانها كبدت ما سمته العدو وخسائر كبيره في
الارواح والمعدات والعتاد حسب قولها
في نفس السياقه سواء المعارك الجاريه في
الشرق لكن اسباب الهجوم
المباغت وهذا القصف والتفاصيله ايضا من
الجانب الروسي الذي طال اقصى الغرب لذيذ
نعم محمد حقيقه في الاسابيع الثلاثه
الماضيه استهدفت الفيف بالتحديد ثلاث مرات
متتاليه المراه الاخيره قبل اسبوع
بالتحديد القوات الروسيه لا تحدد حقيقه
المعطيات المرتبطه والاهداف المستهدفه من
خلال هذا القصف تتحدث في الاحاطه
الاعلاميه من قبل المتحدث باسم وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه تتحدث عن استهداف لمنشات
مرتبطه بالجانب العسكري حصرا ولا تضع او
تفصل في هذا الاطار حول الاهداف التي تقوم
بقصفها ولكن الفيف كما اشرت دخلت في اطار
الاستهدافات منذ ثلاثه اسابيع بكثافه ويتم
استهدافها بشكل اسبوعي هذا الامر محمد
مرتبط بكل المعارك التي تجري على هذا الخط
الذي يشمل ويبدا من مقاطعه او حتى بالاحرم
المقاطعات خارج الحدوديه مع بيل جرود وهو
جعل حاكم مقاطعه بيل جراد
يتحدث يوم امس عن انشاء فوج جديد لحمايه
هذه المقاطعه الحدوديه هذا الفوج من ضمن
سبعه افواج اخرى في المقاطعات الحدوديه
الاخرى التي تتعرض لقصف واستهدافات
اوكرانيا اما في مخص الميدان وتطورات
الميدان اذا ما تبينا من خلال الخرائط
وحتى المعطيات التي اوردتها وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه يبدو ان اعتى المعارك وهناك
استماته في القتال مفقه توصيف المواقع
العسكريه الروسيه في محيط مدينه باخموت
نذكر جيدا انه منذ بدء الهجوم المضاد
حاولت القوات الاوكرانيه مرارا وتكرارا
استهداف مدينه باغوت ولكن وزاره الدفاع
تقول ان القوات الروسيه تصب كل هذه
الهجمات في تلك المدينه كثفت هذه الهجمات
بعد التمرد المسلح الذي قادته قوات فاجنر
هذه القوات التي قاتلت في مدينه واليوم
يجري الحديث عن محاولات لتطويق مدينه
بافموت من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه من كل
الجهات يتم الصد محاولات الهجوم
الاوكرانيه هذا ما تحدث عنه حين قال ان
القوات الاوكرانيه
[ضحك]
باسم قوات الجنوب تحدث ايضا عن صدر هجمات
في محيط مدينه سوليدار هذا الامر يطال
ايضا عددا من الجبهات الاخرى محمد اكان في
ارض يفكا شماليا مقاطعته وشماليه مدينه
دنيا قبل قليل وزاره الدفاع نشرت صورا
ومقاطع مصوره تظهر استهدافات وانفجارات
ايضا في المواقع التابعه للقوات
الاوكرانيه هذه الاستهدافات ايضا انسحبت
على محور مارينكا جنوبيه ولكن هناك حديث
عن قتال موضعي يمكن او حتى وصفته هكذا
هكذا وصفته المواقع العسكريه الروسيه عند
محور
وايضا تستمر القوات الروسيه في الصدق
والمحاولات القوات الاوكرانيه للعبور عند
جسر انطولوب في مقاطعه شكرا جزيلا لك
كارمن جو خضار من مو